[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Norbert König hat
Wintersport für Sie Langlauf und
Biathlon guten Abend und wir schauen auf
diese Themen
keine Verhandlungen ein Jahr nach
Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine erteilt
Bundeskanzler Scholz einem diktatfrieden
mit Russland eine Absage
offene Konfrontation beim G20-Gipfel
trifft Außenministerin baerbock auch auf
ihren russischen Amtskollegen lavroff
und findet deutliche Worte
und die Frage der Schuld nach dem
schweren Zugunglück in Griechenland wird
gestritten was menschliches Versagen
oder chronisches Missmanagement
seit gut einem Jahr herrscht Krieg in
der Ukraine und gut ein Jahr ist es her
das Kanzler Scholz im Bundestag seine
Zeitenwende Rede hielt heute gab bei
einer Regierungserklärung ab und zog
Bilanz
Oppositionsführer unionsfraktions-
ein Jahr Kriege der Ukraine ein Jahr
Zeitenwende ausgerufen vom Bundeskanzler
der macht heute klar er bleibt bei
seinem Kurs
mit der Waffe an der Schläfe lässt sich
nicht verhandeln außer über die eigene
unterwerfen deshalb leisten wir
humanitäre wirtschaftliche und
militärische Hilfe für die Ukraine für
ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger mehr als 14
Milliarden Euro und den zurückliegenden
zwölf Monaten die Union trägt die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine mit
bemängelt aber dass die Zeiten wenn die
an der Bundeswehr bislang weitgehend
vorbei gegangen sei
100 Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr
davon sind nach Stand von heute wenn der
Deutsche Bundestag richtig informiert
worden ist 600 Millionen Euro ausgegeben
und weitere Bestellungen lassen auf sich
warten heftig die Auseinandersetzung als
Grüne und FDP kritisieren prominente
Vertreter der Linken übernehmen Putins
Propaganda wie auch Rechte
tun und den Menschen weiß zu machen als
ginge es um Diplomatie oder Waffen ist
falsch wenn Sie nicht alle so denken wie
diejenigen die an dieser fürchterlichen
Demut teilgenommen haben wenn das nicht
so ist wenn dass sie so denken wie diese
Rechte Fraktion da müssen sie sich von
diesen Kräften in ihrer Partei trennen
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen sie müssen
sich von den distanzieren Widerspruch
von beiden äußeren Rändern im Parlament
wer heute gegen
Kampfbahn zeichnet aus diesem Krieg geht
die Ukraine genauso als Verlierer hervor
wie Russland es gibt wieder nur einen
Gewinner und dieser Gewinner der heißt
USA in diesen Minuten startet der
Bundeskanzler zu einem Arbeitsbesuch bei
US-Präsident beiden es geht um die
Ukraine es geht immer weiter
und der Ukraine Krieg ist auch Thema
beim Treffen der G20 Außenministerin und
Minister in der indischen Hauptstadt auf
eine Abschlusserklärung konnten sie sich
dabei jedoch nicht einigen erstmal seit
Monaten sind dort aber die Außenminister
Russlands und der USA für ein kurzes
Gespräch zusammengekommen und es
Außenministerin bärburg rief auf dem
Treffen ihren russischen Kollegen
lavroff auf den Krieg zu beenden aus Neu
Delhi genommen odental
die deutsche Außenministerin ist nicht
nach Neu-Delhi geflogen um um den heißen
Brei herum zu reden Klartext hat sie
sich vorgenommen und er bekommt das zu
hören Amtskollege lavroff aus Russland
in ihrer Rede hinter verschlossenen
Türen spricht Annalena baerbock ihn
mehrfach direkt an stoppen sie den Krieg
herrlabroff bärbock sieht in Russen
isolierter denn je
hier in diesem G20
[Musik]
dieser Krieg enden muss dass sie alle
endlich Frieden wollen eine direkte
Konfrontation die der Gastgeber Indien
wohl gern umgangen hätte der
Premierminister versuchte früh am Morgen
den Ton zu setzen die Gespräche stünden
natürlich im Zeichen der aktuellen
geopolitischen Spannungen sagt Moody
aber wir sollten nicht zulassen dass die
Themen die wir nicht gemeinsam lösen
können den Themen im Weg stehen die wir
gemeinsam lösen können
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung Energie und
Nahrungsmittelsicherheit Indien Mut sich
die Interessen des globalen Südens in
den Mittelpunkt zu rücken doch der Krieg
überlagert alles zwei die dabei eine
Schlüsselrolle spielen reichen sich die
Hand Russland und China demonstrieren
Verbundenheit wie weit die geht darüber
kann man weiter rätseln
Waffenlieferungen gebe es nicht so
interpretiert jedenfalls die deutsche
dass sie vom Chinesen hört
man hat darauf hingewiesen dass man das
nicht täte was eine gute Nachricht wäre
klingt mehr nach Vorsicht denn Vertrauen
aber derzeit muss man wohl nehmen was
man kriegen kann
und Thomas Reichert vor Ort Thomas china
will vermitteln im Ukraine Krieg steht
aber gleichzeitig an der Seite Russlands
wie ist die Rolle Chinas zu sehen
also China wäre natürlich der große
friedensvermittler aber dafür fehlt
Peking aus meiner Sicht jede
Glaubwürdigkeit das würde auch heute in
Neu-Delhi noch mal ganz klar china steht
eindeutig auf der Seite Russlands hat
zum Beispiel heute eine gemeinsame
Erklärung der G20 die den Angriffskrieg
gegen Ukraine verurteilt hätte die hat
Peking verhindert das wenig Annäherung
durch China vermittelt zu erkennen Ehe
dass China die Blockbildung zwischen dem
Westen und China dem China russlandblock
beschleunigt
am Rande der Konferenz immerhin gab es
einen kleinen Dialog da hat
Außenminister Blinken der amerikanische
Außenminister den russischen
Außenminister Labor auf kurz getroffen
ein kurzer Austausch bei denen es laut
amerikanische Seite darum ging das
Blinken klar gemacht hat die USA werden
die Ukraine so lange unterstützen wie es
nötig ist was darauf selbst darauf
geantwortet hat dazu schweigt die
russische Seite aber immerhin die beiden
haben mal wieder miteinander geredet das
war tatsächlich das erste Mal dass die
beiden Außenminister seit Beginn des
Krieges sich persönlich getroffen und
ausgetauscht haben
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung aus
Neu-Delhi Thomas Reichert
ja und in der Ukraine gehen
währenddessen die Kämpfe mit voller
Härte weiter besonders im schwer
umkämpfen Bach Mut im Osten des Landes
ist die Situation unübersichtlich
Söldner der russischen wagnergruppe
behaupten bis ins Stadtzentrum
vorgedrungen zu sein vom ukrainischen
Generalstab heißt es man wäre die
heftigen Angriffe weiter ab auch die
Stadt saporicia weiter südliches in der
Nacht beschossen worden eine Rakete traf
ein mehrstöckiges Wohnhaus drei Menschen
starben Sex wurden verletzt
nach Angaben aus Moskau hat es
unterdessen auch einen Angriff auf
russischen Gebiet gegeben demnach sollen
in der Grenzregion Brillanz zwei
Menschen getötet und ein Kind durch den
Beschuss verletzt worden sein in
mehreren Videos bekannten sich offenbar
russische Nationalisten zu dem Angriff
die auf Seiten der Ukraine stehen
russlands Präsident Putin sprach von
einem Terrorangriff und berief eine
Sondersitzung des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates ein
man fragt sich was dahinter steckte für
begann Moskau was weiß man stand jetzt
über den Vorfall
also die ukrainische Regierung die weist
alle Verantwortung für diesen Vorfall
von sich und warnt davor das Russland
das ganze habe vielleicht inszenieren
können um zu rechtfertigen eine
Ausweitung der Kämpfe in der Ukraine das
ist eine Möglichkeit die natürlich immer
in Betracht gezogen werden muss aber es
gibt ein paar Dinge die in diesem Fall
gegen eine russische
Desinformationskampagne sprechen zum
Beispiel dass bisher noch weder Videos
noch Fotos veröffentlicht worden sind
von diesen mutmaßlichen Angriffen und
dann eben diese Videos die wiederum im
Internet zirkulieren und auf denen in
denen eine Handvoll Männer sich bekennen
und sagen sie seien das russische
freiwilligen Korb sie seien in das
brillianska-gebiet eingedrungen und
diese Männer rufen die russische
Bevölkerung zum bewaffneten Widerstand
gegen die eigene Regierung auf zumindest
einer dieser Männer ist seit langem
bekannt als russischer Nationalist der
sich in der Ukraine der ukrainischen
Armee angeschlossen hat und an deren
Seite gegen Russland kämpft also ein
etwas verworrendes Bild derzeit noch der
FSB der russische Inlandsgeheimdienst
hat heute Abend bekannt gegeben dass die
Angriffe jedenfalls beendet worden sein
und dass man die Angreifer auf
ukrainisches Gebiet zurückgedrängt habe
vielen Dank aus Moskau für
wegen seiner Nähe zu Präsident Putin und
seine Arbeit für russische
Energiekonzerne gibt es ja deutliche
Kritik am Altkanzler Gerhard Schröder
und aus der SPD den Versuch in aus der
Partei auszuschließen jetzt wurde aber
auch in zweiter Instanz entschieden Gerd
Schröder darf in der SPD bleiben er habe
nicht gegen die parteiordnung verstoßen
so die Schiedskommission des spd-bezirks
Hannover gegen die Entscheidung kann
auch Einspruch bei der
Bundesschiedskommission eingelegt werden
dies gilt aber als wenig
erfolgversprechend
nach Berlin dort hat sich der Vorstand
der Landes CDU einstimmig für
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der SPD
ausgesprochen sie sollen in der
kommenden Woche beginnen mit Kai Wegner
könnte damit wieder ein Christdemokrat
Regierender Bürgermeister werden die CDU
war stärkste Partei bei der Wahl zum
Abgeordnetenhaus geworden die SPD hatte
sich bereits gestern entschieden mit der
cdu-gespräche aufzunehmen
2022 gab es 121 Angriffe auf
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte im Jahr zuvor
waren es 70 so eine Antwort des
Bundesinnenministeriums auf eine Anfrage
der Linksfraktion der Angriffe haben
damit erstmals seit 2015 wieder
zugenommen
Jungs gab es in Greifswald aggressive
Proteste gegen eine neue
containerunterkunft für geflüchtete
Menschen das dabei auch
Rechtsextremisten eine Rolle spielen
zeigt eine Stadtfeld am Beispiel
greifswald
das ostseeviertel am Rande der
Hansestadt Greifswald diese Wiese ist
noch unbebaut die Stadt möchte hier ein
Containerdorf für 500 geflüchtete
errichten im Stadtteil gehen die
Meinungen dazu auseinander die Leute
müssen ja irgendwo bleiben und würde
würden wir in der Lage sein wir wären
auch froh wenn wir irgendwo unterkommen
könnten wir haben hier unsere Autos zu
stehen und man weiß ja nicht wieder über
die Kriminalität bei den Leuten ist aber
immer so ein bisschen Angst vor am
Montagabend versammeln sich 500 Menschen
am Rande einer Sitzung der
ortsteilvertreter demonstrieren
unangemeldet gegen die Unterkunft
darunter auch 20 gewaltbereite und
rechtsradikale der Oberbürgermeister
braucht Polizeischutz um das Gebäude zu
verlassen bundesweit gehen Menschen
wegen der aktuellen Migrationspolitik
auf die Straße rechtsextreme
unterwanderten diese Proteste immer
wieder waren in Experten friedliche
Demonstranten sollten sich deutlich
abgrenzen es ist davon auszugehen dass
Rechtsextremisten nur auf die
Gelegenheit warten das ist solche
Proteste gibt
damit sie nämlich dort sich dann
anschließen können weil ihr Anliegen ist
es ja immer nicht am Rande der
Gesellschaft zu stehen sondern ihre
Anliegen in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
hineinzutragen Greifswalds
Oberbürgermeister Stefan Fassbinder
verurteilt dass aggressive Verhalten
einzelner und sieht die Zuwanderung als
Chance wir müssen zu einer legalen
Einwanderung kommen die unsere
arbeitskräfteprobleme löst die die
illegale Einwanderung reduziert
zumindest geordnete Verfahren werden das
Containerdorf in Greifswald könnte
kleiner als geplant werden darüber
beraten Stadtvertreter zur Stunde
wie kann will und muss sich die
katholische Kirche verändern diese Frage
stand über allem bei der
Frühjahrsvollversammlung der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz ihr Vorsitzender
betzing zeigte sich zum Abschluss
zuversichtlich die Mehrheit der
deutschen Bischöfe Streben nachhaltige
Veränderungen an und stehe hinter den
Reformen Anliegen des Synodalen Wegs
trotz Kritik aus dem Vatikan der
Synodale Weg war nach bekannt werden
zahlreicher Fälle sexualisierte Gewalt
in der katholischen Kirche ins Leben
gerufen worden und willkommene-
nach Griechenland dort sind viele
Menschen nach dem Zugunglück mit
mindestens 46 Toten fassungslos und die
Trauer möchte ich immer lauter die Frage
hätte die Katastrophe verhindert werden
können der zuständige Bahnhofsvorsteher
hat einen Fehler eingeräumt die
Regierung gibt ihr zehntelanges Versagen
bei der Modernisierung zu
an der Unglücksstelle suchen
Einsatzkräfte weiter nach Vermissten die
Strecke zwischen Athen und Thessaloniki
bleibt gesperrt Annette hilsenbeck
sie zerteilen die Trümmer die einst die
vorderen Waggons waren nach und nach
denn die Rettungskräfte wollen alle
Bergen die im Zug waren deshalb wurden
direkt Kräne und Spezialgerät eingesetzt
damit Teile herausgeschnitten werden und
man ins Wrack gelangen kann
Dienstag Nacht war der IC mit einem
Güterzug auf demselben Gleis frontal
zusammengestoßen die meisten Passagiere
waren Studenten aus Thessaloniki gestern
Abend trauerten dort viele um die Opfer
auch in Athen gingen Tausende
demonstrierende auf die Straße
wir Studenten haben uns vor dem
Bahngesellschaft versammelt weil wir
sehr wütend sind und geschockt darüber
was passiert ist und die Schicksale die
vielen leben die zerstört wurden der
Stationsvorsteher der gestern verhaftet
wurde soll die Züge durch falsche
Eingabe auf dasselbe Gleis gelenkt haben
doch die unfallstrecke steht schon lange
in der Kritik weil das elektronische
Signalsystem nur an wenigen Stellen
funktioniert ein 2016 genehmigtes neues
System wurde nie eingebaut heute
streiten landeswahl die Eisenbahner sie
sehen die gesamte Infrastruktur der Bahn
vernachlässigt
das war keine Naturkatastrophe oder
Erdbeben oder Brand das hat sich
angebahnt und die Verantwortung reicht
lange zurück nicht nur zur heutigen
Regierung die steht jetzt kurz vor
Parlamentswahlen unter Druck und spricht
von Versäumnissen
es ist aber auch die Wahrheit dass wir
es nicht geschafft haben diese
auszuräumen deshalb übernehmen wir ein
Stück der Verantwortung dass uns zukommt
nun verspricht man Erneuerung für die
Opfer des zugunglückes kommt dies zu
spät
schon fast einen Monat ist es her das
verheerende Erdbeben im türkisch
syrischen Grenzgebiet hunderttausende
sind seit dem obdachlos
in den Städten liegen noch immer riesige
Schuttberge und in den abgelegenen
Dörfern kommt Hilfe nur verzögert an zum
Beispiel in einigen Ausläufern des
Taurusgebirges Isabel Thymian hat eine
deutsch-türkische Hilfsorganisation in
karamanmarscht
schon früh am Morgen werden die LKW in
kardamanmaras beladen die Mitarbeiter
von Hassani einer internationalen
islamischen Hilfsorganisation packen
Babywindeln Lebensmittel und Heizkörper
in die Autos der Leiter der Organisation
ist aus Deutschland angereist um sich
ein Bild von der Lage zu machen
es ist wichtig dass man die
Gesundheitsversorgung aufrechterhält wir
beobachten dass es einige neue
Krankheiten noch gibt auch dadurch dass
die Hygiene nicht gewährleistet werden
kann also in vielen Gebieten gibt es
bisher noch keine Möglichkeiten sich zu
waschen
es geht in die Dörfer im Taurusgebirge
hier kommt wenig Hilfe an von den
staatlichen Organisationen
selbst ist stark betroffen vom Erdbeben
früher einmal wohl haben das
Handelszentrum jetzt in weiten Teilen
Trümmerwüste und auch in Woche 4 nach
dem Leben gibt es in vielen Stadtteilen
immer noch keinen Strom und sauberes
Wasser
David niemand von der Regierung kam uns
besuchen in unser Zelt in der Nähe des
Rathauses heute sollen wir das Zelt
verlassen warum
die LKW von hasseln erreichen nur
langsam die Dörfer in den Bergen es
liegt immer noch etwas Schnee in
kemmerley der erste Halt Familie
hildarim ist hierher in die Berge
geflohen ihr Haus in der Stadt ist
zerstört
wir werden hier eine Weile bleiben weil
das in der Stadt so viel Smog gibt durch
den Staub der Trümmer und es ist für uns
und unsere Kinder gefährlich
die hilfstransporter müssen weiter die
Menschen in den Dörfern werden wohl noch
lange auf ihre Lieferungen angewiesen
sein
trotz der weltpolitisch schwierigen Lage
funktioniert die internationale
Zusammenarbeit auf der ISS vom
Weltraumbahnhof
Rakete mit zwei amerikanischen einem
russischen und einem Raumfahrer aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
gestartet morgen wird die Crew an der
internationalen Raumstation erwartet sie
soll einen Teil der aktuellen Besatzung
ablösen und sechs Monate dort verbringen
die saxophonlegende Wayne shorta ist tot
der us-jazzmusiker und Komponist starb
heute im Alter von 89 Jahren Schotter
gilt als einer der einflussreichsten
Musiker der Jazz-Geschichte im Verlauf
seiner langen Karriere später mit Größen
B Miles Davis und Herbie Hancock
[Musik]
und wir kommen jetzt zum Sport im
Planitzer ist heute ein weibliches
Quartett aus Deutschland an den Staat
gegangen und hat im Ziel wirklich
lautstark gejubelt Norbert 20 km geteilt
durch vier starke Frauen ist gleich WM
Silber und das hat es bei nordischen Ski
Weltmeisterschaften lange nicht gegeben
nur Norwegen ist in der Endabrechnung
schneller als die dsv-läuferinnen
Gimmler Hennig Fink und Karl
Silber gewonnen und extrem glücklich
über diese starke Leistung die natürlich
erhofft aber auch von Schlussläuferin
Victoria Karl nicht unbedingt zu
erwarten war ich konnte im ersten Moment
gar nicht glauben ich war einfach noch
so fokussiert und dachte mir so das hast
du jetzt nicht im Ernst geschafft nach
Überraschung selber bei Olympia im
letzten Jahr gewinnt die deutsche
Frauenstaffel nach 12 Jahren ohne
WM-Medaille wieder Silber
ich bin super glücklich und super stolz
über unser Ergebnis heute dass wir es
nochmal erreicht haben wieder eine
Medaille zu schaffen zwischenzeitlich
kämpfte sich Katharina Hennig sogar auf
Platz 1 vor und dann war es vor allem
auch Pia Fink die als dritte Läuferin
überraschte und allen Angriffen von
Schweden und Finnland trotzdem so
letztlich auch die starke Viktoria Karl
bedeutet platz 2 für die deutschen
Langläuferinnen hinter Norwegen
er ist ein biathlonphänomen und einfach
nicht zu stoppen der Norweger Johannes
ting ist zuletzt in Oberhof mit fünf Mal
WM Gold dekoriert hat in November wir
schon zum 12 mal ein Einzelrennen der
aktuellen Weltcup-Saison gewonnen
der weltcupino im jesto einmal mehr
Ausdruck der Dominanz von Johannes
thingsbüll der Norweger bleibt über die
10 km Sprint Distanz ohne Schießfehler
und sichert sich seinen 15 Saison Sieg
damit gewinnt der vorzeitig den Weltcup
im Sprint sein
älterer Bruder Taha zweiter exakt eine
halbe Minute langsamer den
beeindruckenden norwegischen vierfach
Erfolg komplizieren Christiansen und
dröhnsheim auf dem Plätzen 3 und 4
bester Deutscher Roman Rees im Ziel nach
einer Strafrunde knappe eineinhalb
Minuten Rückstand auf den Ausnahme
Athleten bedeutet Platz 8
immerhin noch einstellig danke Norbert
beim Wetter geht es um Sonne und Nebel
mehr dazu gleich von öst Intelli das
heute journal können Sie um 21:45
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das umfangreiche
hoch über Großbritannien beeinflusst
auch das Wetter bei uns so ist es über
Deutschland Frankreich und Spanien
trocken und kaum Regen ist dabei dafür
bildet sich in der Nacht vor allem nach
Norden hinnebel und der kann ziemlich
dicht sein Nebel und Nebel am Boden und
auch Hochnebel sind dabei so ähnlich
auch nach Süden in der zwischen gibt es
aber Bereiche da wird es sternenklar
sein bei tiefsten Temperaturen von -8
Grad in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen
sonst -5 bis 2 Grad aber häufig
Temperaturen unter der Null Grad Marke
Morgen wenn sich der Nebel auflöst zeigt
sich durchaus die Sonne es kann aber im
Norden durchaus längere Zeit dicht
bleiben nach Süden gibt es einige
Schneeflocken viele wird es nicht sein
sonst aber häufig Sonnenschein bei
höchsten Temperaturen von
bis acht teils elf Grad Richtung
Rhein-Main-Gebiet dort wo die Sonne
nicht hervorkommt in den Nebelgebieten
etwa 0 Grad die nächsten Tage ja etwas
Regen und Schnee ist dabei zwei bis neun
Grad am Samstag und danach ein bisschen
kühler damit ein schöner Abend